vuelven las largas filas para hacerse
pruebas pcr en beijing algunas partes de
la ciudad se transformaron en lugares
dedicados a realizar pruebas masivas en
un intento de contener un nuevo brote de
omicron el distrito de chaoyang de
beijing registra actualmente el mayor
número de casos
estoy preocupada sobre todo porque
trabajo en el distrito de chaoyang así
que me preocupa que pase algo allí el
despliegue de las pruebas masivas ha
despertado el temor de que se produzca
un cierre al estilo de shanghai en la
mayor ciudad de china 25 millones de
residentes han sido confinados en sus
casas durante semanas con un acceso
impredecible a los alimentos ante el
temor de correr la misma suerte los
residentes de beijing se están
abasteciendo aunque el número de nuevos
contagios sigue siendo relativamente
bajo en la ciudad las autoridades dos se
arriesgan y se aferran a la estrategia
de kobe cero pues todos los nuevos casos
se han puesto bajo control la capital se
encuentra actualmente en una fase
crítica de prevención en control de la
pandemia
beijing reportó 33 nuevos contagios del
martes una cifra mínima comparada con la
de shanghai donde se registraron 16.000
nuevos casos y 52 nuevas muertes